à chaque fois même tu sais plus où aller
on joue au jeu des plus beau c'est quoi
bah on regarde les pubs mais il faut
trouver pourquoi c'est quasi je suis
chaud à ces trucs moins ok je ne jouais
au hockey chaud ça je pense que c'est
une pub de voiture ouais non je pense
pas t es de la musique et tout ya tout
un délire défi au rythme de la nouvelle
skoda fabien quoi gagner vite été trop
fort aurait nié en fait c'était facile
il venait à peine juste de dire le
chemin la vase il fait chaud on fait
vraiment mal ça tu vois ça ça peut être
ça peut être tellement de trucs ça peut
être soit une plus de voitures c'est une
pile de voiture ça pareil j'en suis sûr
si six voitures ouais ça serait quand
même bizarre qui a un ego mewes vivent
ça c'est facile vous êtes trop fort tous
les deux là c'est un truc de fou
bon ça va c'est quand même plus ouvre
que deviner des pubs de voitures cacher
je sais je dis ça parce que je suis un
peu surprise puisque freddy par exemple
il n'avait jamais joué c'est ça non
jamais ben voilà acquiesce je vais
trouver la prochaine ok moi chaque matin
je prends soin de mes dents dentifrice
puis je monte dans ma twingo car la
route n'a pas tué mais [ __ ] mais
comment ça calme toi on s'en fout laisse
tomber c'est un jeu tu veux on peut
jouer à un autre jeu enfin je veux dire
un jeu plus facile à morpion j'ai dit
que j'allais trouver un temps que je
vais en trouver un ok je vais trouver un
président en place sont les seuls à
jouer ça arrive une fois et on se dit
que ce n'est pas grave
on n'ose pas avoir la vérité enfin je
dirais que c'est un truc de prévention
raquette ou harcèlement mais ce n'est
pas tout
plus dur ce n'est pas de voir la vérité
en face le plus dur c'est d'en parler à
voir là c'est ça c'est un truc de
prévention yes alors qu'en parler mène
souvent à de nouveaux horizons
[Musique]
a lancé plus de voiture c'est plus de
voiture c'est plus de voitures ce n'est
pas toujours alors c'est un truc de
prévention se retrouve une prévention
c'est sa fierté ce que j'ai dit c'est le
premier truc que j'ai dis donc c'est un
point et puis voilà un point en cas il
existe un numéro pour vous yes ainsi
qu'un site inter c'est bon ne vous
laissez pas abattre
je lai qui conduisait la nouvelle clio
les lanternes et comment ça se fasse pas
croire ça peut prendre la tête pour
enjeu tout péter là c'est bon ça va
aller calme-toi mais voilà si elle et
qui reprend de toute façon un bon jour à
une autre fois bordeaux c'est fini mais
nous savons aussi que je vous jure c'est
pas moi qui l'a assassiné
obligé cellule tueur effet vous êtes
innocent car le tueur n'est autre que la
nouvelle citroën 500 et 18 tonnes
ça c'est le moment on doit dire abonnez
vous voilà tu as trouvé là c'est bien à
nice en fait un point conduisait la
toute dernière abonnez-vous c'est une
pub encore rester moi même et on réalise
c'est une pub c'est une pub pour notre
chaîne en fait j'en trouve recul me fait
chier on peut tricher avantage c'est une
pub pour nous c'est une pub pour nous
bravo à nice